hi this is presh talwalker here are
three puzzles that prove mathematicians
believe in ghosts
puzzle one
a father leaves 17 goats to his Three
Sons
his will specifies that one half of the
goats go to the oldest son
one-third to the middle son and
one-ninth to the youngest son
but there is a problem
17 cannot be split evenly to any of
these fractions
so how did the Suns divide up the goats
fairly according to the father's wishes
puzzle two
you have several identical bricks and a
ruler
you want to measure the distance between
two opposite corners of a single brick
without using any formulas
so you cannot use the Pythagorean
theorem for example
how can you do it
puzzle three
at 6am a monk started climbing a
mountain and he reached the top at 8 pm
where he slept
the next morning at 6 a.m he descended
on exactly the same path and reached the
bottom at 8 pm
he may have had a different speed and he
did not use necessarily the same speed
during the entire trip
a mathematician observed that even with
these considerations there must be a
spot on the mountain that the monk
occupied at exactly the same time on
both days
why is this so
give these puzzles a try and remember
these are three puzzles that prove
mathematicians believe in ghosts
when you're ready you can keep watching
the video and I'll present the solutions
alright puzzle one
how can 17 be divided into one-half
one-third and one-ninth
the trick is to add a ghost goat that
makes the total 18.
one half of 18 is nine
one third of eighteen is six and
one-ninth of eighteen is two
the oldest son gets nine goats the
middle son gets six goats and the
youngest son gets Two Goats
and now here's the neat part
we can now let the ghost goat disappear
and now the Suns have divided the goats
according to the father's wishes
puzzle two
how can we measure the distance between
opposite corners of a single brick
without using the Pythagorean theorem
what we'll do is we'll create a ghost
brick
we'll stack two bricks on top of each
other
and put a third brick next to the bottom
one
you can see there's a spot left for a
fourth brick which is now
a ghost brick because this brick is not
really there
but we can measure the distance between
opposite corners of this ghost brick and
that will give us the answer no formula
is required
in the third puzzle a monk goes up a
mountain and then he climbs back on the
same path
so how do we know that there's a spot
that he occupies at exactly the same
time on both days
well what we could do is instead of
having the trips take place over two
days
we'll imagine as the monk is climbing up
the mountain
we'll have a ghost which travels exactly
the same path the monk would take going
down but we'll imagine this takes place
on the same day
this is possible because both trips
start at 6 a.m and end at 8 pm
so when the monk is climbing up his
ghost goat is his the Ghost monk is
coming down and necessarily at some
point the two pets will have to cross so
this is a spot on the mountain that the
monk occupies at exactly the same time
on both days
did you solve these three puzzles
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
Game Theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google Plus and patreon you
can catch me on social media at Presto
Walker and if you like this video please
check out my books there are links in
the video description